♪ [music] ♪
- We are the paradoxical ape, bi-pedal,
naked, large brained, long the master of
fire, tools and language but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive. We shape the
future from our shared understanding of
the past. CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines to exchange
insights on who we are and how we got
here. An exploration made possible by the
generosity of
humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Ray] I should first give equal billing
to Eva Wittenberg who did a lot of this
work with me. Can you identify yourself
there? Yay, right there. One of the big
questions for anthropogeny is, "How did
language evolve in our species?"
This is a big question. My almost
five-year-old granddaughter asked a couple
of weeks ago, she asked, "How did people
make up words when there weren't words
before?" So I mean it's an obvious
question. Well here's the thing.
Languages are learned by children and
their progress looks like learning other
things like motor skills and social
skills. So a lot of people think there's
nothing more to it than that. Humans just
got to be good at learning stuff. So I
want to restate the question not, "How did
human language evolve?" but, "How did
humans evolve so as to be able to learn
language as well as all those other
things?" And in order to answer this, you
have to ask another question, "When you
learn a language, what do you end up
knowing?" For starters knowing a language
is being able to map between patterns of
sounds or gestures on one hand and
meanings, or thoughts or concepts whatever
they are. So something like this. So when
you're speaking, you're going upwards in
this picture from meanings to producing
sounds, and when you're understanding,
you're going downward. Now let me add a
little bit of the big picture. Conceptual
structures are also linked to perception
and action. So you can talk about what you
see and you can talk about what actions
you plan to carry out and so on. Now just
for fun, what do you get if you take away
phonetic patterns like this? Well you get
an organism that can perceive, and have
thoughts and act based on those thoughts.
And I think this is a plausible sketch of
ape cognition, which is pretty
sophisticated, but it doesn't have
language. So the evolution of language had
to involve at least a new ability to map
concepts to sounds and gestures
and to use these communicatively.
Well we've been hearing this all day.
Well linguists actually think there's a
good deal more to that than language.
First comes phonological structure, which
is the systematized organization of sounds
or gestures, and we just heard about that
from David Perlmutter in ASL.
Second one is morphology, the
internal structure of words such that a
word like, say "procedurally" can be seen
as built from "proceed" plus "ure" to form
"procedure," plus "al" to perform
procedural, plus "ly" to perform
"procedurally." And the third one is
syntax, the organization of words into
phrases and sentences. So syntax
determines things like canonical word
order. So if you hear something like,"The
boy kissed the girl," you know who did
the kissing and who got kissed. It also
allows you to elaborate descriptions of
characters and events into phrases. So
something like, "The boy in the blue hat
and red sneakers tried to kiss the girl
that he loved," and you still know that
the boy did the kissing, even though the
word "boy" is nowhere near "kiss," and you
also know that he the loved the girl even
though "boy" is nowhere near "love." So
language in modern humans involves this
part circled in red of the network of
cognitive organization. And what's evolved
in humans is the ability to learn to do
this kind of thing to turn thoughts into
sounds by structuring them into words
and phrases and to be able to pull
thoughts out of the sounds that other
people make. Well how could this have
happened? Basically there's no direct
evidence for what our ancestors talked
about and when they started talking. There
aren't any fossil vowels. The usual way to
test evolutionary scenarios is comparison
to other species. But here it isn't too
helpful as we've heard already today,
modern apes don't learn very much in the
way of human languages, and they certainly
don't invent language spontaneously as
deaf children do in the absence of sign
language input as we also
have heard about today.
So there's a big cognitive gap between
apes and humans here. Another way to form
plausible hypothesis about evolution is
through reverse engineering, figuring out
what components could have been useful in
the absence of others. So think about the
eye. A primitive retina would have been
useful for vision without the muscles that
move the eyeball although it might be
more limited than our modern vision. On
the other hand, without a retina the
muscles wouldn't help you see at all. So
it makes sense that something like the
retina probably evolved before the
muscles. I want to propose something like
that for language. So a primitive system
for communicating thoughts via sounds or
gestures is useful without phonology,
morphology or syntax. These components can
improve an existing communication system,
but they're useless on their own. So if
the components of language evolved in some
order it makes sense that the connection
between phonetics and meaning came first,
and then these further refinements going
from there to. . . So the hypothesis is
that this is the kind of system that some
ancestors of modern humans could learn.
I can't prove that this is the way
language evolved, but what I'll try to do
today is to show you the simpler systems
of this sort exist in the languages of
today and show you a little bit
about how these systems work.
And the basic idea comes from Derek
Bickerton. He proposed that there's a form
of language that he called
"protolanguage," which surfaces in many
different circumstances, and he proposed
that this form of language is a relic of
early stages in the human or Hominid
system. I'm going to suggest that this
form of language is a subset of the full
language system. It omits morphology and
syntax and I'll call it a linear grammar.
What is a linear grammar like?
Well it has words and the words have to
come in some order. They map to meanings
but there's no structure. There aren't
syntactic phrases like, "The boy in the
blue hat and red sneakers," or structure
inside words as we saw with the word
"procedurally." Now in this kind of
language, word order could still matter.
You could say, "Boy kissed girl," and
mean that the boy did the kissing and the
girl got kissed, not vice versa, but it
wouldn't be because the subject precedes
the verb and the verb precedes the object.
Because a linear grammar can't have
syntactic things like nouns, and verbs,
and subjects and objects. What it still
has is semantic notions like the word
denoting an actor here, "the boy" precedes
the word denoting the action namely
"kiss." That is this kind of language
would map directly between linear order
and phonology and the meaning. Now a
linear grammar doesn't have morphology,
so it can't have things likes tenses and
agreement on verbs. So you'll get, "Boy
kiss girl," not "Boy kissed girl" or "Boy
kisses girl." You'll leave it up to the
context to indicate when this kissing took
place. And you might also expect not to
have functional items like definite
articles, which perform more of a
syntactic role, namely marking noun
phrases than a semantic one. And a linear
grammar is linear, so it can't have
subordinate clauses like the relative
clause in "The girl that he loved." You
might still express this thought but
maybe as two sentences. You might say
something like, "Boy love girl. Kiss
girl." Something like that. Well I want to
tell you about some systems that look like
this. The first one is pidgins. These are
the early stages of contact languages as
we also heard about earlier today. This is
great. This symposium just set up my
talk perfectly. Pidgins are often
described as having no subordination, no
morphology, no grammatical words like
"the," and they have unstable word order
that's governed by semantic principles
like actor before action.
If the context permits, you can leave out
characters in the action. So if you
already knew about the girl you might
just say, "Boy kiss," where English would
make you use a pronoun like, "The boy
kissed her." So from the perspective of
linear grammar we can ask, "Is there any
evidence that pidgins have parts of speech
like nouns and verbs? Is there any
evidence for syntactic phrases?" And my
preliminary conclusion is there's very
little evidence for it and suggests that
pidgins would be a good example of a
linear grammar. Later on of course
contact languages add many features of
more complex languages like
conventionalized word order, grammatical
categories, syntactic subordination
again as we heard today. And these kinds
of languages are called creoles. And Eva
and I see the transition form from a
pidgin to creole as going not from it's
not a language it's just junk to a
language. Now it's a language. But just
adding some syntactic and morphological
principles that weren't there in the
pidgin just goosing it up a little bit.
For a second case, Wolfgang Klein and
Clive Perdue did a multi-language
longitudinal study of immigrants all over
Europe learning second languages. And they
found that all speakers achieved a stage
of what you might call semi-proficiency
that Klein and Perdue called the "basic
variety." Many speakers went on to improve
on it, but others just stopped there.
That's as far as they got. And in this
stage as they describe it there's no
inflection or morphology, no tenses, no
plurals and so on, no sentential
subordination. You can leave out known
characters freely. There's simple and
semantically-based principles of word
order including
our favorite
actor before action. That is from
our standpoint the basic variety also
looks like another kind of linear grammar.
Third case is home sign. As we've heard
already the languages invented by deaf
children who have no exposure to a signed
language and Susan Goldin-Meadow has
shown that they have at most rudimentary
morphology. They freely emit known
characters. And on our analysis they only
have a semantic distinction of object
versus action not a syntactic distinction
of noun versus verb. The word order is
kind of probabilistic, but if anything
it's based on semantic roles. Home signers
do produce some sentences with multiple
verbs or action words if you don't think
they have verbs. Goldin-Meadow has in the
past described these as embedding. We
think these are rudimentary serial verb
constructions, which I can't explain to
non-linguists, I'm sorry without
embedding. So it looks to us like a linear
grammar with possibly a bit of morphology
added. And I should add to be perfectly
honest Goldin-Meadow does't agree with us
altogether. So this is controversial.
Another case we've looked at is village
sign languages, which develop in isolated
communities where there's a significant
occurrence of hereditary deafness. And the
best known of these is ABSL, which we've
just heard about from Mark Aronoff. I'm
going to talk about Central Taurus Sign
Language or CTSL, which is spoken in a
couple of remote villages in the mountains
of Turkey. This language came to my
attention two years ago thorough my
student Rabia Ergin who remarkably has
deaf family members who live in the
village and speak it. You want to raise
your hand, Rabia, our new celebrity? There
she is. Rabia, along with Naomi Caselli,
Irit Meir and some of the people from
Carol Padden's group from about which
we've heard already have been documenting
this language. And what they find is that
the language has a fair amount of
morphology, but there's very little
evidence for syntactic structure in
sentences involving one character.
So somebody jumped or somebody fell down
or something. The word order is normally
the actor preceding the action. If there
are two character sentences with inanimate
patients like, "The boy rolled the ball,"
it's normally well maybe you put in the
actor maybe you don't,  and then you put
in the thing that's acted upon and then
the action. But if there are two animate
characters, so the semantics alone can't
resolve the potential ambiguity, word
order isn't very stable. It's a bit vague
whether they boy kissed the girl or vice
versa. And there's a lot of reliance.
People rely a lot on pragmatics and
context. In fact, there's a very strong
tendency to mention only one of the
characters in an event no matter how many
there are. So a CTSL looks like a linear
grammar augmented by a substantial amount
of morphology and this isn't too far off
what we've seen in ABSL and the earlier
stages of Nicaraguan sign languages we
heard from Annie Senghas. Now what's cool
I think is that these less complex
systems aren't confined to emerging
languages. Townsend and Bever discuss what
they call "semantically-based interpretive
strategies" that influence language
comprehension. Hearers tend to rely in
part on semantically based principles of
word order like actor precedes action
which is why on our story they have more
difficulty with constructions such as
reversible passives and object relatives.
Again, for the non-linguist, it doesn't
matter. Where the actor doesn't precede
the action. That's the crucial thing.
Similarly Fernanda Ferreira and her
colleagues discussed what they call good
enough parsing where people apparently
rely on linear order and semantic
plausibility rather than syntactic
structure. And it's well-known that we see
similar symptoms in language comprehension
by a grammatic aphasics. And Heather
van der Lely has argued that a particular
population of children with specific
language impairment behave as though
they're processing language through
something like a linear grammar.
The literature describes these so-called
strategies or heuristics as something
separate from language, but there's still
mappings between phonology and meaning.
They're just simpler ones that bypass
syntax. So we conjecture that the language
processor makes use of both syntactic
grammar and the simpler linear grammar.
And when the two kinds of rules produce
conflicting analysis interpretation is
slower and less stable even when the
syntax wins out. And when the syntactic
rules break down under conditions of
stress or disability then the linear
grammar is still there doing its thing.
We've also come across two full-blown
languages whose grammar appears to be
close to a linear grammar. And others have
come along that I haven't looked at very
closely yet. But one of them is Riau
Indonesian. This is a vernacular with
several million speakers described by
David Gil. Gil argues that this language
has no syntactic parts of speech, no
inflection or morphology like tense, or
plural or agreement. Known characters in
the discourse are freely omitted, and
things that English expresses with
syntactic subordination are expressed in
Riau by simply jamming simple sentences
together like "Boy kiss love girl." The
word order is pretty free, but actors tend
to precede actions and actions tend to
precede patients. But here's some
illustration of the freedom of this
language. If you have the expression
"chicken eat," this can mean all of
these different things depending on the
context. And the ones at the bottom, where
you say, "Chicken eat," and you mean
someone is eating with the chicken. They
require a lot, or where the chicken is
eating, they require a lot of contextual
support, but people do say these things.
So this again looks like a linear grammar.
So here's basically a full language that's
syntactically simple in our sense.
Another example is the controversial case
of Pirahá studied extensively by
Dan Everett. This has exuberant
morphology, so it's not simple in this
respect. It seems to have a syntactic
noun-verb distinction and fairly fixed
word order, but no definite or indefinite
articles, no markers of plurality, no
agreement. Now Everett's most famous
claim is that Pirahá likes recursion that
is subordinate clauses. Everything that's
expressed in English with recursive syntax
either just jam simple sentences together
or require some sort of circumlocution. So
this looks like a syntactically relatively
simple language, though not a simple as
Riau Indonesian. So to sum up we find
that's remarkably similar grammatical
systems turn up in all these different
scenarios, and it suggests that linear
grammar is quite a robust phenomenon
entrenched in the modern human brain. It
provides a scaffolding on top of which
fully syntactic languages can develop
either in an individual as in the case of
the basic variety or in a community as
we've seen with sign languages and
creoles, and it provides a sort of safety
net when syntactic grammar is damaged as
we've seen with aphasia and specific
language impairment. And we've also seen
that you can say a lot without syntax for
example in Riau Indonesian though having
syntax gives you a lot more fancy tools
for expressing yourself. So let me go back
to the original question about the
evolution of the human ability to learn
language. I suggest that we can think
about it through reverse engineering
asking what kind of system there could
have been that preceded the modern human
language faculty. And I think linear
grammar's a good candidate. As I said at
the beginning, I have no idea how we could
prove it nor when the Hominid line
achieved either linear grammar or
syntactic grammar. Maybe some day we'll
get better evidence from genetics.
But for now I'm happy to see it as an
intriguing hypothesis. So altogether then
we think this is telling us a lot of
interesting and new things about the
texture of the human faculty, and I'm
eager to get on with filling
in the picture further. Thank you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪